all right if you've bothered watching
the fake news media in the past 24 hours
which I do not recommend you may have
noticed they have a new obsession and a
new target to fame their moral outrage
at and they have decided to
hyperventilate and go wall-to-wall with
hysterical coverage about me now the
media in this country is zero
credibility we have known this for over
a decade you know we've been exposing
the media for what they really are they
are frauds they are partisan hacks and
frankly nothing more than extension of
the Democratic Party all things liberal
and pretty much all they do is parent
liberal political talking points and of
course attack president Trump 24/7 all
in an attempt to damage-dealing chitta
Mises presidency so naturally when
people dare to tell the truth about the
president and his accomplishments and
report on what is the biggest abuse of
power scandal in American history yeah
I'm not surprised I've become a 24/7
target the media wants to tear this
president down that's what they want
they hate conservatism they hate anybody
that dares to challenge their rigid
radical left-wing ideology you know all
of this perfectly explains why they've
been going so hard after me and just
simply refuse to believe the truth that
I told them and by the way it's not the
first time they've done it to me and
others and it won't be the last now
thankfully people are seeing what's
happening other conservatives are
calling out this massive double standard
this hypocrisy from the liberal media
and God knows the so-called journalists
won't do it themselves earlier today the
king of talk radio Rush Limbaugh the
great one Mark Levin both exposing what
the liberal media is doing let's start
with Rush here's what he said on his
radio show earlier today let me tell you
what this this this this so-called this
attack on Sean Hannity is what it really
really is it is another in a long line
in a many years effort to destroy the
credibility of advocates for
conservatives slash
Republican or anti Democrat issues and
personalities the purpose of this is is
not to put Hannity in legal jeopardy
although they would love to if they
could but the real purpose here is to
simply discredit Hannity is a known
effective public advocate for Donald
Trump Donald Trump is the enemy Donald
Trump must be sent packing Donald Trump
must not politically survive and the
people who make effective cases for
Trump are going to be hit and are going
to be targeted but there is so much
glaring hypocrisy that really Frost's me
that hypocrisy never sticks to these
people on the Left they define collusion
they define conflict of interest
they are architects of deceit they are
never forthcoming about who they really
are and if you try to find out if you
try to do an investigative report on
some of these people they start
squealing like skunk pigs that you can't
because they're protected by the First
Amendment they are journalists and to
such they're never the story you can't
talk about them an amazing takedown by
Rush and he's right the media cannot
stand the fact that there are people
like us that challenge the liberal
partisan worldview they hate that we
want the country under President Trump
to actually succeed and help The
Forgotten men and women that need jobs
that are in poverty out of the labor
force or on food stamps that we believe
in the Constitution that we believe in
equal justice under the law equal
application under the law we support
Reagan style free-market principles and
a strong national defense now the media
also can't stomach that we expose the
deep state and one of the biggest abuses
of power in American history which they
have been ignoring
despite mountains of evidence for months
as they go with their unproven
conspiracy theories so I'm not surprised
that the media is going after me it's
predictable it's pathetic now here's the
truth the media is guilty of every
single solitary thing they have been a
key
using me of over the last 24 hours the
media is the sewer
they are the swamp and there's part of
this incestuous corruption and conflict
and they sure as heck don't want to talk
about or care about transparency here's
just a few examples why take a look at
ABC News George Stephanopoulos a
so-called journalist that secured the
first interview with disgraced former
FBI director James Comey the guy who
literally is carrying out a personal
vendetta against President Trump now to
George Stephanopoulos ever disclose the
fact that during the interview that he
worked on Bill Clinton's 92 presidential
campaign and was a communications
director and then served in the Clinton
White House as a senior advisor and
since the liberal media appears to be
suffering from amnesia here's a clip
from the documentary it's called the war
room yeah George Stephanopoulos
advocating for the Clintons take a look
what his name's address I can send you a
fax with names addresses phone numbers
of who you had an affair with it
wouldn't make it true
it is completely if you went on the
radio and said that blew Clinton is the
father of illegitimate black child you
would be laughed at
you would think you're crazy I guarantee
you that if you do this you'll never
work in democratic politics again maybe
you don't want to I'm not saying it
matters you will be embarrassed before
the national press corps people will
think nobody will believe you and people
will think you're scum you'll be
embarrassed never work in national
politics again sounds like a threat did
George Stephanopoulos reveal any of that
before during and after the sit down
with Comey remind his audience or how
about the fact that George donated 75
grand to the Clinton Foundation which of
course he didn't reveal to his viewers
during an interview with Peter
Schweitzer back in 2015 Stephanopoulos
he had to apologize after being exposed
but there wasn't wall-to-wall coverage
over that and all it explains why
Stephanopoulos put on the kid gloves and
didn't ask James Comey the tough
questions now one thing is just the fact
I am honest about Who I am and what my
political beliefs are I am an
unapologetic unapologetic conservative I
am a trump supporter I support Reagan
economic
policies and peace through strength for
example where was the follow-up question
when Comey admitted he didn't tell
Donald Trump that Hillary Clinton paid
for the unverified dossier which by the
way was used to get a FISA warrant to
spy on an American what's this did you
tell him that the steel does he had been
financed by his political opponents no I
didn't I don't even think I used the
term steel dossier I just talked about
additional material but did he have a
right to know that that had been
financed by his political opponents that
I don't know the answer to that it
wasn't necessary for my goal which is to
alert him that we had this information
oh wait George Stephanopoulos he's a
journalist right well why didn't he ask
call me to respond to the information in
the Grassley gram memo that the bulk of
the FISA application to spy on a trump
campaign associate consisted of the
dossier that he didn't vet that he had a
legal obligation an FBI protocol
obligation to do and why didn't
Stephanopoulos ask if Comey lied to a
FISA Court and federal judges on four
separate occasions by not revealing that
the dossier was funded by Hillary
Clinton in the DNC whose finances she
controlled why didn't Stephanopoulos ask
call me to respond to what his former
deputy director Andrew McCabe said about
the dossier without it there never would
have been a FISA application and the
list goes on
now Stephanopoulos he lobbed up softball
question after softball question never
challenged or pressed Colby why should
he he got the first interview why should
he he's friends with the Clintons then
over there at fake news CNN you have
Jake Tapper I'll just let the great one
Mark Levin handle this part Jake Tapper
Jake Tapper was a spokesman for Marjorie
Margolis Mezvinsky who is a congress
moment or was from the 13th
congressional district of Pennsylvania
her son married Chelsea Clinton I
mentioned that too does Jake Tapper ever
mention that no does Jake Tapper ever
mention he was a spokesman for handgun
control Inc no well sort of fake news
CNN they ever disclose all of this when
he hosted CNN's gun control Town Hall a
few months ago and I wonder if Jake is
gonna disclose all of this on a show
tomorrow I
doubt it none of this should be
surprising now according to the Center
for Public Integrity back during the
campaign 96% of presidential campaign
donations from journalists they went to
Hillary Clinton you heard me right 96
percent well all those people now come
clean about their political
contributions and their support for
Hillary Clinton what about as WikiLeaks
exposed that top journalist from ABC
Bloomberg CNN MSNBC the New York Times
many of these outlets remember they
dined at a key Clinton staffers house
right before Hillary launched her
campaign ate their food drank their wine
if all those journalists did in fact
attend why didn't they tell you about it
or how about these relationships does
the media find these problematic you got
reports Virginia mostly a senior vice
president at CNN married to Thomas
knives who served as the Undersecretary
of State for Hillary Clinton
we know Claire Shipman reporter ABC
married to former Obama White House
press secretary Jay Carney former Obama
national security adviser Susan Rice her
husband used to work at ABC News does
the media find any of this troubling
this is only a small sampling of stuff I
could bring up did they raise red flags
about any of this then there is the
epitome of the Washington DC sewer and
swamp the dozens of journalists that
went to work for the Obama
administration Media Research pointed
out the total number reached as high as
30 it got so bad that back in 2013 even
the liberal Washington Post was forced
to cover it and ask this question so
what to make of all of the family ties
between the news media and the Obama
administration great question the answer
is nothing no one in the media cared
because their savior the chosen one
Barack Obama was president but if Fox
News Channel contributor goes to work
for the White House god help us all
it was the highlight of these
journalists careers to suck up and
defend Obama's disastrous record they
never vetted him and they never told you
how bad his achievements or lack thereof
were eight years later later the media
doesn't care about truth anymore they
don't care about facts they don't care
about ethics they don't care about
holding themselves accountable
they have what is a clear obvious
liberal agenda and they share a common
goal with liberals in this country the
Democratic Party they want to destroy
the president now we have showed you
that reaction on election night it was
like a funeral their attacks against the
president it is getting more unhinged
every day and for the media to pretend
they have any sort of moral authority is
just laughable it's a joke and you the
American people know it
that's why poll after poll shows you
don't believe them and you don't trust
them and you see the bias for what it is
now we're gonna end with this key point
members of the media it put their
blinders on and are purposely ignoring a
massive scandal which would be the
biggest story in their lifetimes and if
they care so much about conflicts of
interest like they claim I dare them to
report on this corrupt mulher
investigation and his team that a
stacked full of Democratic donors and
Muller's buddy with James Comey and
Comey had a friendly potentially
classified information to the media so
that that Muller in fact would be
appointed and Muller has assembled a
team that has donated over 50 grand to
Obama Democrats Hillary and the DNC gave
no money to Donald Trump and Muller
handpicks Andrew Weissman who has the
most atrocious track record including
withholding exculpatory evidence and
convictions in the Enron accounting
scandal overturned by the Supreme Court
nine zero people went to jail that was
overturned by the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals or Muller his own involvement
when he was in Boston four people went
to jail two of them died in jail they
were all innocent and over a hundred
million dollar judgment was paid out
after the fact now congressman mark
Meadows is also revealing tonight that
newly uncovered documents suggest a
quote concerning level of coordination
between the DOJ and the FBI during key
moments of the Clinton email
investigation which we have talked about
at length on this program or how about
James Comey and Trump hating FBI agent
Peter struck and all these other people
putting the fix in on the Clinton email
investigation it's immediate they don't
even mention it it's unbelievable how
corrupt they are if they cared about
truth and journalism and about being
fair and balanced and all of these
things they would be reporting these
things to you every night but in their
sanctimony they think they are holier
than now
all right cry me a river